george floyd's brother that's philonous
floyd and the family's attorney ben
crump
joining us now from minneapolis good
morning to you both gentlemen
fellaini floyd i want to start with you
because i'm thinking of your family
today this has got to be very emotional
and very triggering
how did you all prepare for this day
oh we just prayed a lot because we're
praying family
we talked about what we we know they're
trying to do they're going to try to
assassinate his character
so i'll be in there and george he will
be with me
and my lord and savior jesus christ will
be with me also
then how did you tell the family what
did you tell them about what they can
expect
during this trial
what we told them as fallonia said that
they're going to call his brother
everything but a child of god they're
going to try to say gail that
because he had a trace amount of drugs
in his system
that that's what killed him and not what
we saw in that video
where he was tortured to death for eight
minutes and 46 seconds
and gail we rebuke when people say this
is a hard case
this murder case is not hard you just
look at that torture video of george
floyd
had george floyd been a white american
citizen
nobody would be saying this is a hard
difficult case
you know ben when you look at the tape i
do think many people feel
it has to be a slam dunk but that is not
the case that's not how the system works
and there are so many things the defense
is saying that
the public has not heard
you know gail again that is something
they're trying to do to distract us from
what we saw on that video
gail for eight minutes and 46 seconds
his
knee is on his neck if that is not
intentional
you don't know what is even under the
geneva convention definition
of torture this would be a crime
so the question is in america are we
ready finally to have equality and
justice
for all even if you are a marginalized
person of color
ballonas you know the world is watching
this case it certainly has larger
implications for the community and for
the world what do you want to say to the
community
we get the sense except especially in
minneapolis that people there are on
edge as they're watching this
i just want to thank all the protesters
for going out
fighting through a pandemic with
covetous they put their lives on the
line for what was right
and i want to thank them for that the
community is doing everything
they can to make sure we get a
conviction because they're always saying
and they always state it
no justice no peace they march
you know ben the other thing yes sir he
his cause of death was
uh overdose of excessive force
the american uh autopsies conclude
that the manning cause of death was
asphyxiation by homicide
any and everything else you're going to
hear today is just an
attempt to assassinate his character now
that they
unjustly killed this black man yeah
well the defense does seem to be laying
the groundwork talking about substances
that were found in his system i'm sure
that there's going to be more to that
during the trial i want to talk to you
ben about cameras in the court
you know we're hearing that has never
been done in the state of minnesota
before that they are going to allow
cameras we will see we will not see
the jury but we will see see the process
do you think that this is a good idea
i think it's a very good idea and it's
very important because we have to have
transparency with after 50
million people saw this video around the
world
and probably more on uh
social media and if people
then have a result that they don't
believe the process was fair
and transparent what we saw in may and
june
with the protests would be child's play
to what we will see in the aftermath of
this verdict
that's why it's important we have
transparency people got to know
that it was fair for george floyd's
family
not just for the police officer polonius
i want to talk to you about your brother
i watched his
his service and i watched you in
particular you were talking about he's a
big guy
6-4 you talked about making banana and
mayonnaise sandwiches i was wondering
about the sandwich toys
but you were talking about making banana
and mayonnaise sandwiches and that
he was known as a general in the
neighborhood he would walk around and
people wanted to be around him
and wanted to talk to him what do you
want us to know about your brother today
as the trial begins
oh man he he was an amazing person he
helped a lot of kids not only by
cutting their hair and teaching them
sports he also helped them with their
homework
he took them to the ymca that was the
closest
place that we can go to and have fun
with each other besides being at home
sleeping in the same bed eating off the
plates with each other
we cook with each other we did a lot of
different things
um my mom would call him her freak of
nature because he was so big
oh we we loved our brother uh and
a lot of people around the world loved
him and uh you can see that
by the way that people march around the
nation uh they're not just doing this
for anybody
they're doing this for somebody who they
know should still be here living
and speaking right now with us he is
certainly more than a hashtag to
you and many people in this country we
thank you very much for joining us this
morning we'll be watching thank you both
we will bring you a live special report
when the trial begins it's all set to
start at 10 o'clock eastern
9 central